how do you kill something that's already  dead  and the answer is it's a big fat pain in  the ass  katie cooper contacted me  and and said hey we're going to put some  dc characters into a horror world are  you interested i stopped cole when it  got to rock because i'm like i read him  he's low tech old school  and  he's just a great soldier but in any of  these fantastical stories you get one  gimme and to give me is hitler can bring  soldiers back from the dead  sergeant rock provides the answer of  who's going to take care of business as  he says to his own guys i don't know how  they do it and i don't care  our job is to stop it  it's a pretty good marriage of artists  and subject matter he's great with  characters he's great with faces he's  great with mood and that's everything in  a horror movie mood is two-thirds of it  i'd hire rock way over ash  any day of the week  you